Whenever there is a great unjustice
happening; a criminal walks freely.
I dropped my sandwich
an animal dies for no good reason
that's when I put my foot down, and I say
UGHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
I get mildly irritated when these things happen.
people dying from war;
Clipping your nails a slightly too long, so it feels weird.
These are all mildly irritating things that makes us go
Ughhhhhhhhh
Sometimes that anger just gets too built up, and you need to let it go.
You need to move past it
by really letting out a fierce
UGHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
I'm with you 100%.
There is just too much injustice in this world.
So let's explore it together with other people and see what we can find.
(ANGRY MONKEY)
My stress ball just exploded that is honestly so annoying
Because then you gotta clean all that up. I think it happened once one of the stressed boobs
Oh, yeah, it did happen to Ken
He asked me what the f I was taking a picture of I told him I was taking a pic of the douchebag that needs
to occupy two handicap spots to eat some fries is it weird that I would do this to say as well
I mean if there's no handicap th- (laugh)
I'm just saying if there's no handicaps
Why did the spot needs to be open I can clearly just move out of the way listen
There's only one spot when I collect my mail that is free and it's always just a handicapped spot where am I?
Supposed to park this is not my infuriating
Actually, you know what it is ERR! for the wrong reason stop discriminating at people parking at handicapped spot
There's nothing wrong with it
There's a stigma-
spend hours completing this mildly infuriating puzzle, and now I can't
Yuh. I guess that's mildly infuriating. What do you want me to say? This is pathetic
This is all that you have to bother your life and take one step in my shoes
And you would feel real pain. you would feel real my lead in whatever five bananas. Well maybe
One of the bananas isn't a banana have you thought about that before judging your anger?
Maybe you should think critically like me before you LETasdhas
Let your emotions pity thoughts rule over your mind and body. I haven't agreed with a single one so far (laugh)
I thought this would be mildly infuriating..
These pencils suck
Then don't buy them what the hell all these crybabies
Jesus Christ.
this dad mailed a container of sliced mangoes to his daughter in college
(O__O)
ERRRRRRR!!1!1!!!
This is not interesting (chuckle)
make me so angry
ERRR!1!11!
Stupid daughter ERR!!... I don't care about your sliced mangoes
EER !!!  EER !!! EER !!
There's more important information that I could fill up my mind with
ERRRRRRRRRR!!!!!
Stupid pat- father and mango. I don't caaaaaare
I don't care about this article from BuzzFeed.
having screenshots saved in a screenshot
Does that actually happen..?
that is so infuriating
ERrYY!!!!     ERRRRRRRRRRR!!!!!!!
I'm not gonna read this post
ERRRR *chuckle
People who whore out sus- unsus- (go back to school felix)
people who whore out unsuspecting relatives for virtual numbers my daughter does not think I can get
98 likes for being 98 years old can we prove her a wrong, please share one like equals Respect
how about something interesting?
these pity
Anything just does... these kids just think anything deserves likes these days
How about 98 likes to kill your grandad, then I will like it then it would be interesting don't waste my time
ERRRRRRRRRR ERRRRR GAAAHHHH!!!!!
Gillette now sells four pack of blades instead of five packs still the same price and even the same Packaging *chuckle*
theonly thing infuriating about this is that Dollar Shave Club won't sponsor me. What is up with that?
ERRR!
No rush, you got lots of time. Oh shi-
What is this?
LaUgH
ERRRR!!
I was hoping I could wait 60 more seconds ERR!!.. that's so annoying
smash 399
Quaker Oatmeal
advertises
35% less sugar but in reality they're just selling
35% smaller portions
Lower sugar Wow
That's brilliant, I hate UPS just a little bit more every day
I'm working from home down stairs, and I'm hard of hearing please ring the doorbell or yell. I'm here. Thank you
Sorry, we missed you yeah, they loved handing out these goddamn things. I don't even want the package
This is why I park at the handicapped spot at the post office
I need my revenge oh, I know something that really irritates
commenters
If I have my headphones not balanced what y'all mad about today Professor X could move anything with his mind
So why not his F-ing legs?
This is what I'm talking about the handicapped spot, you know what's actually mildly infuriating about this
It's the amount of time people spend talking about comic book heroes, and why would that doesn't make any sense.
GOD I just realized that Professor X can't have sex it never occurred to me that his d doesn't work either F
Man, I'm surprised. He's such a positive guy
knowing that he hasn't had sex in years
now im just sad
I'm not infuriated
You know what that is infuriating this guy has been talking on the phone for 10 minutes with this flashlight on
just tell him excuse me sir your flashlight is on you are burning more battery and
Blinding other people is that so hard instead you just take an Alford photo to upload and reddit
*chuckle* look at these guys
Pathetic your all EERR-
im ERRING for the wrong reason... what makes ERRR even more!
ERRRRRRRRRR!!
i like they're trying to say CLASS OF 2015
2 0
2 0 4? *chuckle*
*clap clap clap clap*
Congratulations the American school system you have outdone yourself yet again, but that's my dad's middle name
What is your father's middle name Paul enter an answer that is at least five characters clearly his name is not Paul
It's something else
Clearly your dad is lying to you
YEE !! EHHHH!!
Sorry
That was a bit much. I am I do apologize. I was staring at it all flight
Oh, she's wearing. She's wearing the right headphones in the last
It's another thing huh I had if I have my headphones not balanced as well
It's all people comment about in the comment section thinking they're like so
So quirky about their OCD when you really you're just a bunch of crybabies
Do you have such a perfect life that this literally mild inconveniences
This is bothering you. This is bothering you in my ball. I'm sorry am I bothering you right now. Am I bothering you
Maybe she was facing the seat the whole time
Why can't they design their cables better, and it's just so annoying stop buying Apple products you dummies
Do you think it's impossible to make them more sturdy and better you think they're not just trying to make you buy new cables
You think there's a reason because if you plug in other?
Off-brand ones Apple won't even approve them you have to buy their own ones
Stop buying Apple products, and then I'll buy into your stuff crying this this whole video is just me getting hankering
For the complete wrong reason being stuck behind this for miles, just go around
They said there's this you can nearly just go around. What's the problem? Oh?
Like you know both are their speeds if one is going
Half a mile per hour quicker, then it shouldn't take miles
For you to wait get there wouldn't it you dum-dum scum bum booty, but I watch two for tonight
What you don't want to watch colorful videos for kids what youtube this makes me actually
This lady watching a beach wedding they put up a yellow police tape all around the beach
Yet somehow this random lady in the blue swimsuit
still
fascinated
Someone needs to shoot that that woman, this is why I'm for the Second Amendment
Why why do I need an account just to look at Pinterest? This is by far the highest one?
Why are people using Pinterest then that's my real question?
Yeah, you search for Google Images you get a Pintrest result. Oh ok apparently. I won't view this picture
Sukkah yeah
This better be good the most tense 13 days of the Cold War occurred during the event known as stiff
Cuban Missile Crisis wrong correct answer Cuban Missile Crisis
selca yeah
speaking of cyka
Guys this is the last chance you'll get to buy this merch
Check out represent calm slash PewDiePie and become a real black
today very nice
very
Nice-nice chance guys. Thank you. Everyone that bought it so far really appreciate it
Thank you for watching this video and let me know leave a like if you're and leave a double like if you didn't
And I'll see you guys in the next video. Goodbye
I'M TRIGGERED